that's it because a lot of people hear
that message but I don't want to I don't
want to dream so small no I'm not asking
to dream small like dream big dream
bigger we're just building the plan to
actually get there because the thing
that's missing between where most people
are and where they want to be is they
don't have the team and the resources to
do it so let's go get you some more
resources so you can get the team to go
off and build your even bigger Mission
if you were to sell your courses and
they're in Sweden or sell your
one-on-one time and they're in Sweden
you could build a six-figure even seven
figure business just off of this which
then gives you the funds to hire a team
to go to the world you've got this big
mission of what you want to do amazing
and like how many people need what
you've got like the whole world needs
what you got who doesn't need self
leadership help everybody needs it it's
a question of what's the order to go in
so that it gives you the best chance
yeah success
I have a issue because I speak Spanish
and I also have this Swedish and
sometimes what is stopping me is like oh
I should have in Swedish I said no no I
have I should have it in Spanish and I
cannot decide what to to do or should I
do too but I also afraid that if I start
to doing both
then I would not do because it's so much
job to do and what about English and I
also speak in Russian and I also you
know
yeah yeah you're a woman of the world I
love it
so okay let's start with this before we
get to a specific tactic what are you
selling so it says mindset code who do
you sell I work with the people with
mindset but I also work a lot with
values
and the cultural organizations and
Leadership
especially value-based leadership and
what language are most of your current
clients speaking English some of my
programs are in English but the group
coaches that I have are in Sweden in
Sweden but I want to take my I am
originally from Panama
so I wanted to to take my knowledge to
the to my country or to I know other
Latino countries
so this really becomes a question of how
long can you wait what I typically try
to do with entrepreneurs especially at
this stage is like let's figure out how
to bring a lot of value and make a lot
of money and
what's like what's the fastest way to
get there so that you can hire a team to
help you do all the other great things
that are in your head
because if it's if it's you alone Alicia
doing like almost all of it that's a
problem because you run out of time and
now I have four different channels that
I need to manage and run and then like
nothing happens right that becomes a
problem so you you do a lot of stuff not
you but like in general someone who
would be in your situation or maybe you
I don't know you can let me know
um
end up like doing everything in a really
just okay way instead of really
dominating one thing typically the
easiest thing to do to build momentum if
if English is not like if you if America
is not your target market uh it's not
what you're you're living right now uh
is in your market so like usually the
easiest thing is in Sweden yeah because
you're there and you can build you can
build connections there and you can
create content there and every language
that is not English is behind with
content so if you're talking mindset and
you're talking leadership and you're
talking self leadership and all of the
things that you talk about
English is going to be the most
competitive there's the most people
talking about that stuff there's there's
Tony Robbins and Brendan burchard and
Mel Robbins and all these other people
talking about it's not that you can't
win you can't it's just it's gonna take
longer you have to be more patient you
have to get better
where in Sweden who is talking about
this
probably some people but not as many
they're not as good
and so it's easier to win but the market
is smaller that being said you can build
this up so that when you are if you were
to sell your courses and they're in
Sweden or sell your one-on-one time and
and they're in Sweden uh you could build
like a good business off of this like
you can build a a six-figure even seven
figure business just off of this just
off of Sweden which then gives you the
funds to hire a team to go to the world
where most people make a mistake is they
want to do it all all at once and then
nothing happens right like Panama is
awesome there's not a lot of money in
Panama for most people
so it's a it's a service and are will
there be people in Panama who can pay
you yes but yeah Panama is not Sweden
yes and Panama is not America it's it's
very different yeah for the budgets that
people have right so I I would love to
see you set up success in your Market
make a lot of money help a lot of people
and then you you take that team and you
you can go and go to the world like I
have a Spanish Channel with a million
subscribers we have a Russian Channel
almost with a million subscribers
but I'm not doing much on those channels
I can invest in those countries in those
languages because we've had success in
the English Channel so it's like you've
got this big mission of what you want to
do amazing and like how many people need
what you've got like the whole world
needs what you got who doesn't need
self-leadership help everybody needs it
it's a question of what's the what's the
order to go in
so that gives you the best chance yeah
success yes yes does that make sense and
also I have the the question about the
the content because sometimes I say oh I
will focus only in self-leadership but
then I start to thinking oh maybe
the leadership totally in the whole but
there is so much in the in the
leadership
or should I only focus on
self-leadership that is
very important here
again
there's a difference between what do you
ultimately want to sell and build and
create and like what can we sell right
now because again if you had three
people helping you with your social
media content you can do a lot more than
just at least by herself making content
right
me with my team right like I can make a
lot more content because we have 40
people Plus on the team I didn't I
didn't a team no I wouldn't be talking
to you right now because I'd be like I
need to make a I need to make a YouTube
video I need to edit it I need to you
know like we wouldn't be as big so
so then you take that same we took that
philosophy and we brought it to the
markets right so we're gonna we could
start with Sweden first and then go to
other languages other markets cool same
thing with your content what do we sell
so are you currently selling what I
heard at the beginning and you tell me
if I'm wrong it was mindset leadership
and self leadership mindset is the self
leadership
so you have self leadership and then
leadership leaving yourself and leading
others you have products and services
right now to sell to both of those the
self-leadership I have I Evergreen
program two Evergreen programs
um and but the for the leadership is
more one-to-one at the moment so
whatever you want to sell now let's have
content around those things so if you
can sell leadership programs and
self-leadership programs then content
should be around self-leadership and
Leadership
so if you're going to do two pieces of
content like say you're going to do two
videos a week on YouTube One video is on
leadership one videos of self leadership
next week same thing leadership self
leadership you're going to go to
Instagram you want to do four pieces of
content a week
two on leadership two unself leadership
like whatever you want to sell that you
can sell right now that's what we make
content on because if you're only doing
self-leadership stuff people don't know
but you talk about leadership
the same thing the other way yeah
they're close enough like if you were
going to do
um self-leadership and then World Cup
or or just something organic gardening
or something just completely different
okay that's a different Channel that's a
different channel right or actually more
important for you language is a
different Channel yeah
so if it's in since
um Swedish don't put English content or
Russian content or Spanish content on
that same channel because most people
don't speak those languages yeah that's
true so they only consume for what they
what they speak so I would have a
um
like even so at least Jessica knows I'm
looking at now it looks like it's mostly
Swedish content although there's some
English content oh it's a mix sometimes
I would make it a different I would make
it like it's Swedish like go I would go
all in on Swedish win in the Swedish
Market start making some money so you
hire somebody who can then help you take
over all your social media who can then
help you go into English Market Spanish
markets Russian markets whatever if you
speak eight more languages that's great
too
somebody who speaks English now listen
how many how many people in Sweden speak
English a good percentage a lot almost
everybody learns English growing up yeah
in Sweden right I'm sure there's some
people who don't but like it's an older
generation who may not be your clients
anyway you know if you're talking to the
business World entrepreneur World
corporate world they all speak English
but it's their second language versus oh
she's like she's one of us she's here
she's from Sweden because your name
doesn't sound Swedish because Espinoza
is from Panama right so I don't know
that if I were to see your name and if I
would look at you I wouldn't think oh
yes in Swedish right but if the content
is in Swedish and I can hear you talking
in Swedish and having content around you
then if I'm in Sweden I'm more likely to
want to hire you than if you're like
English content very good so it becomes
a how does how does Alicia help the
world cool we're gonna we're gonna hit
five markets eventually or five
languages or four languages but but
where we're gonna start so it's just a
matter of I don't want you to I Don't
Want You To Dream smaller I just want to
make it easier to go in order it's the
sequence it's just how do we start to
make it easier for you when I start to
thinking like of this and this language
and this it would be so overwhelming
that then I it will be like paralysis by
analysis you know
should I do this now should I do this
now so so it's a good good idea I have
to say it's overwhelming if you have to
do everything yourself
and you teach this you teach leadership
right you teach leading other people
right so you know when there's a team of
people helping you can just do a lot
more than if you do everything by
yourself it's overwhelming because
you're doing it all where if you had
team members and ultimately like I have
a my Spanish team was in Argentina
and they manage the the Spanish Channel
and they take the videos and they dub
them into Evan's Spanish voice and
they're making content and I I don't
even speak Spanish so uh but they like
they run the whole thing right that's
not good you're not happy I can get by
in Italian and French but uh yeah it's
close enough if I if I read Spanish I
can kind of make sense because Italian
and friendship listener if all you have
to do was make content like if you're
gonna film videos you could film you
would you would have time to film videos
in English Spanish Russian Sweden if you
have to do all the other stuff around it
of editing and titles and thumbnails and
descriptions and captions and posting
and clicking the button like because you
have to do all that yeah it takes away
time
when I need to do everything the
consistent consistency will be lower
because he said oh my gosh I need to do
this and I need to do this I I need to
take care of my clients so you know so
and I want to be a great coach for my
clients so so it's it's why it's so
important to have the consistence and
sometimes I am not because the the the
doing everything and the same you're
normal that's most
that's most people yeah most people are
not consistent and and then you get
another idea go I should go I should do
this this is great and then like yeah
but you need to stop posting right so
that's why it's important it's like
what's the fastest way to start making
yeah some money
and yeah you're obviously you're making
money you have clients like how do we
make more money ten times more money
so that you can hire somebody to do all
the stuff that you don't want to do it
because it's fun at the beginning but
then it can easily get boring yeah I
don't want to do this anymore so
um yeah to sit down and and plan now
that I know that I can do the these two
leadership and Leadership and mixed
together in the same
and Swedish
that's a good good idea yeah it is it's
easy it's a lot simpler right and then
the goal then becomes okay so let's say
who is it all you right now you have
anybody full-time part-time where are
you at part-time
but she needed to quit so I need to find
another person so so I can work with
and you need a you need a full-time
video part-time VA because
um yeah I think that at the beginning in
a part-time
DBA so great and with the VAB be posting
to your social accounts also I would
like to have some some person helping me
with the the finishing of the you know I
can write what I want to say and so but
somebody to to fix so it's nice so and
so they they post
yeah also that's not a full-time job you
only need somebody full-time that's like
super part-time
um but but that's it it's like okay so I
need a part-time VA I need a super
part-time yeah copyright copywriter to
kind of finish the writing
um maybe a part-time video editor or
your VA can do some of that or like how
you create the the if you're using canva
or whatever to make your Instagram post
or maybe your maybe your VA does that
right so that could still be part of
your va's work but if you think okay
to really start to make a lot more
content and better content all you
really need is a part-time VA and a
super part-time copy editor yes like
maybe you can already afford to hire
those two people right now I don't know
uh maybe you need to just bring on two
more clients and then you can afford to
hire those people right so like that's
where it's like hey all you need to do
is go get two more clients and then we
can start to build a team out which then
gives you more content to then go
recruit more clients right yeah and so
now we start having momentum because you
can invest
copyrighted but not fine yet the the
right person you know if you need to to
click with me sure but you know if you
made it a priority you you asked
everybody that you know in Sweden do you
know a copyright writer I need somebody
part-time you look at anybody who is
posting in in Swedish that you like
their stuff anybody who whether they're
reporters or journalists or influencers
on Instagram or whatever like any
anybody who you like their style of
writing like if you yeah you're the
mindset of self-leadership person right
yes if you really wanted to find that
person yeah you know yeah by the end of
the year you could right I think so much
about that but
you know I was like okay I meet this
person but I don't know it wasn't so
good yeah yeah and I I have a lot of
some people to do something for me and
and the quality has things like that not
in my
how I like it so it's why yeah it's
testing and trying more people you know
it's like the um
it's like imagine if the first person
you ever dated to be the person you
married for the rest of your life right
it's you know you you go on a couple
dates you get to know people you see
what's right right the most people just
don't talk to enough people you know how
many copywriters have you actually yeah
to do this maybe three yeah
yeah
if you talk to 30 you would find
somebody yeah that's it and that's it
and and here's you you could like it may
not even be the priority right now the
priority right now is let's go get two
or three more clients
so that they can pay for the VA and the
part-time carburetor
can then help you create more and better
content yeah so that you attract more
clients so that then you can invest in
no yeah right so I am just keep going
for the next year and in there I have a
goal to to create a team
so so we can work together find the a VA
and a copyright yeah in Sweden so that
speaks Swedish
and even oh yeah 100 yeah you don't want
to you don't want me to copyright your
stuff right I mean
but the problem is when they write is
more like Google Google translator so
it's no it's specializes here in Sweden
for the VA maybe but yeah for the VA
maybe but the copywriter has to know
what they're doing and that's super it's
like that might be like an hour a week
like it doesn't have to be a lot but
this is where when you're thinking about
I'm going to build out a team right I'm
going to build a team okay great you
have your goals for 2023 awesome and
later on not less maybe hire somebody to
help you make English content or Russian
content or I'm going to open up
something in Panama or whatever right
you need team but the first set stage
one is
VA and part-time copy editor right and
you can assign a budget that's not going
to cost a lot of money right the
copywriter May cost you more it will it
will cost you more per hour but you're
only hiring them for one to two hours a
week this is not a big job at least
right now the VA will will take up a lot
more time but cost you way less per hour
so you can put together a monthly budget
to say okay how much is a video gonna
cost me per month how much is the
copyright gonna cost me for eight hours
per month and then it's gonna cost you
that much okay and then how many clients
does that work out to one new client two
new clients three new clients right and
so that's all you need that's like
that's stage one right
stage two might be a video editor
um a videographer somebody to help you
dial in your your Panama strategy right
like there's
the our ideas are endless you know
you've got big ideas I've got Big Ideas
you want to change the world right and
that's great and it's great like dream
dream big and okay
it's it's then this gets so easy to get
lost in our Big Dreams and it's like
well what do I what do I do we're
building the ladder we're creating the
bridge we're getting in the boat and
we're rolling like this is the first
step and and what's great is you already
have a product service that you can sell
so some like I don't know what I'm gonna
sell I don't know who I can help I don't
know what my skills are like you've
already figured that out which is great
so now we just need to figure out okay
uh how many clients you need to need to
get so that you can get that team those
two people
and then you'll feel so you'll have so
much more momentum like just imagine an
EA or a VA taking 20 30 hours a week of
work off your plate what does that free
up for you to do
yeah
yeah right a lot like maybe maybe you
can already afford to hire that person
now and if it's not 20 hours a week
maybe it's five hours a week or 10 hours
a week right
um yes that's how you put the scale up
yeah but it's these steps
because a lot of people hear that
message today but I don't want to I
don't want to dream so small
no I'm not asking to dream small like
dream big dream bigger
we're just building the plan to actually
get there because the thing that's
missing between where and not just you
where like most people are and where
they want to be is they don't have the
team and the resources to do it so let's
go get you some more resources so you
can get the team to go off and build
your even bigger mission
yeah
that will
[Laughter]
yes sir
yes sir let's go we're building all
right how do you how do you how do you
say that in Swedish what's like yes sir
in Sweden
I know why
Susan okay I know that one okay you you
honestly I know zero Swedish so you
could have said anything
this Swedish at the moment it's like
that's okay no problem
as soon as we hang up yeah it's Gonna
Come
and you're like
[Laughter]
what happens to me all the time
the whole conversations in Paris gave me
ideas about how to
grow my with my podcast I was contacted
with two companies
one it's about supplements to promote
their product on my podcast
and the other it's uh active weird
for sports
okay the problem is when it's mentioned
that I'm in France may I can't apply
well okay so listen so for people
watching you know the strategy was if
you're gonna host a podcast bring on
people that can be business development
for you so that it's not just other
coaches or other people in your industry
it's people who could potentially refer
you clients and Mina went on an amazing
Health Journey how much weight did you
lose kilograms seven kilograms I don't
know what that is in pounds I think
pounds but yeah but she went back to it
you went back to your University weight
and then you've kept it off like this
I'll I'll you know since then
yes more than 15 years now I keep the
same baby shape yeah and so she teaches
other people how they can do it as well
and the idea with the podcast was okay
what are some of the companies that if
they knew who you were would potentially
introduce you to clients so uh first up
great like congrats on on reaching out
to two companies and starting to make
some some progress and traction there uh
the two things I would look at is one
more
you know more if you only have two
companies then it's really like oh my
gosh I have to make this work
versus if you had a hundred that you're
reaching out to now it's not as it
doesn't it doesn't matter as much like
if one company is slow or one company
says no or one company you know doesn't
respond or whatever right
um so I think we do this a lot because
we put so much pressure on like this one
thing having to work and then if it
doesn't it all falls apart where we just
need just more volume so two is great
two is better than zero and now we need
you know 98 more to go reach out to and
see whether it might be a fit uh and
then two
when when uh when the front door is
closed and the back door is closed you
go through the window
you know so if they're if their their
process is you fill out this form oh
you're from France you can't apply okay
that that's the front door
so what's the windows you know it might
just be I don't know how big the company
is but it might be finding who the CEO
is and messaging her on Instagram or on
Twitter or if it's a really big company
maybe it's the the VP of marketing
there's somebody in marketing and
messaging her on Instagram or on Twitter
right just like okay we have this path
and it's often not usually the path that
like everybody's trying to go to the
front door and so that has the most
resistance
it's the hardest to get through
so you climb through a window and you
find another way through to make it work
so that company that you like both of
them could be fits and if they're saying
no or they're not you know they have a
web form and because you're in France
they're saying you know you can't apply
cool
you reach out and find another way and
say hey I'd love to have you as a guest
on my podcast and share your story
that's a good idea
yeah even even in that like even the
whole idea of having a show
to do business development is already
going through the window and set it to
the front door because
whether it's the activewear company or
was a supplement company that you're
talking to uh they get hit up all the
time with people trying to make deals
trying to do Partnerships uh so you're
one of many people trying to reach out
but they don't get connected with enough
with people who want to share their
story
they don't get a lot of interview
requests so that becomes a path you're
going through as media now instead of
just the usual path as a partner and
it's easier to get a yes to come on your
show and tell their story
yes so the good news uh is that I
created my YouTube channel let's go Mina
this is great
it's not
um active yet but it will be soon so it
will be on the same topic and the
interviews I did for the podcast I will
meet them on my YouTube channel
okay great I'm thinking about affiliate
marketing to inter introduce in
in the description of videos
so you can the thing with affiliate
marketing is you need to have
real volume to make it work if you look
at coaching for example like how much is
your you have a bunch of programs but
what are the price ranges for your
programs to work with you
the first uh
offer it will be 497 dollars okay
and what's the highest offer that you
have what's the price
497. okay so every person who comes in
uh that you're going to start working
with is either basically 500 or 2500
that's good like that's um that's some
good money for people coming in if you
go to affiliate marketing
if you look at you know let's take
activewear and let's take supplements
which are the two companies that you're
talking to and you can go to you can go
to books it can go to other things as
well too but the commission rate is
usually pretty low
and the volume off of first sale is
and so you might make the problem with
affiliate marketing is you need you need
lots of scale to make it work so
you know let's say even in a generous
case like if one in a hundred people
that's very generous right would like
click and buy something from it from
your YouTube video so you have you know
one person and how much you're gonna
make five bucks off of a off of a
commission ten dollars off of a
commission like it's it's not a lot of
money off of each one
compared to
if somebody signs up for your program
and now you're making 500 or or twenty
five hundred dollars so it's not it's
not bad to have it could add a little
bit of a bonus I guess if you're putting
it in the description below but most
people don't read the description unless
you call it out in the video like if you
made a video about the supplement or the
activewear or something then you'll have
a much higher percentage of people
clicking through otherwise people don't
really look at the description
um so there's nothing wrong with doing
it it's just probably not going to make
you that much money and if you had a
choice between where you spend your
energy you want to spend it on the
things that will have the highest return
now if you had a million people watching
your videos then affiliate marketing
makes a whole lot more sense right uh
because because those ten dollars and
five dollars start to really add up but
at the beginning when you have you know
you just started the channel you have no
videos yet but it's coming but the best
thing to sell is you so it's your your
your training your coaching your 500 or
2500 packages that's where most of the
effort should be a lot of work to do
well here's the thing is like it's it's
also trying to make it easier so it's
not as much work right so the whole idea
of affiliate marketing makes more work
for you because now you got to find the
companies you got to find the links you
gotta update the description you got to
sign their agreement see it like it's
it's work to do all the affiliate
marketing stuff with at the beginning
very little results
so I wouldn't worry about it
so like if you're if you're overwhelmed
by work and lots of things to do
no not really because I'm consistent uh
on doing it the only thing that I'm not
consistent is showing up and Market my
podcast and this is my big challenge is
to show up on Facebook on Instagram on
Tech talk uh but I'm planning to show up
minimum twice a week
so as to start to go there and to talk
about the podcast so that'll be a better
use of your time
because if the goal of the podcast is
you're going to bring on people who if
they knew who you were leads to business
for you so you're going to bring on a
supplement company entrepreneur or a
fashion wear or sportswear entrepreneur
or whoever else that relates to your
industry if if the supplement company
entrepreneur loves you and loves your
story and you love their products
they don't sell coaching
they sell supplements no so could they
sell coaching could they refer you to
some of their clients could you work it
out that
sure somebody's buying supplements but
maybe they're not consistently buying
supplements because they don't have a
program that they're on they need
someone like you to come in and give
them a program
and help them figure out even what
supplements to be on and for how long
so if the goal of having a podcast is to
bring on people like that who then if
you had 10 people on one two three of
them start referring you to their
clients
and then every client you bring on
that's 500 each or 2500 each or
somewhere in there right so if if you
interviewed if you interview 10 people
who are all potential ideal fits for you
and three of them refer people on to you
or send an email out talking about you
uh and then out of that you get
40 people who sign up for your program
you know that's a lot more than you'd
make off of affiliate marketing right so
it's uh spending the effort on
getting booking the people so doing the
Outreach so you've done two amazing
that's a great start now it's like how
do we get it to 100 and then extra time
would be working on promoting the
podcast making content doing clips for
Instagram and YouTube shorts Etc
um
that's where I put extra effort in
because the bigger the podcast gets the
easier it's going to be to get people on
your show to say yes
yeah and the last such a day I
participated in um Summit Health Summit
and it was organized by different
coaches and I was invited to talk about
my story
and it was interesting because we
decided to do challenges from time to
time and to talk and each one market all
the other coaches
so it's a manner to talk about my
podcast as well
yeah the thing with those challenges is
seeing that there's a lead anywhere you
know so you did one one is just a great
experience because the more you get a
chance to talk about your story the
better and and you'll get better at it
every time you tell the story you get
better and you get better you get better
and you get better being a part of a
summit is great because there's there's
a live audience and there's also a
replay audience
um the model is usually
let's have all of the people come on
then email their lists and everybody
brings a few people or however many
people and create this Summit it really
just depends on who's in there and how
big their lists are
to see how many people actually show up
um but in that that model can work one
just to get the experience and then two
you're thinking does this is it helping
me get business
so at the beginning it might even not
matter if you get business or not from
it because you're telling your story
you're practicing in front of a new
audience building a relationship with
the other coaches may not be as valuable
because they're they're selling the same
thing as you maybe not the exact same
thing but close and what's exactly the
same thing for example one is
um keto diet another one is essential
oil for example specialized in essential
oil and each one has her business so
it's different from my Approach right so
but your approach is very nutrition
heavy right it's a holistic program a
holistic approach
um Nutrition Fitness and mind body heart
soul everybody has their own modality
and that's great
if somebody's going to hire somebody
right if you think about somebody coming
to the summit who's trying to learn and
they're going to then work with somebody
would they work with both you and the
keto person at the same time
I don't like maybe but probably not
but would they work with you and the
essential oils person at the same time
Maybe
maybe yeah maybe but but that's it
that's the kind of thing of like okay
they're not they're not direct
competitors and I don't really see like
competition like that but it's more if
somebody's coming on it's like who you
can develop a business relationship with
you want like with the keto person ever
refer business to you
I don't think so probably not right so
so so nurturing that relationship is
probably not strategically a good
decision if you just love that person
and you share entrepreneurial advice and
it's great being around other people
it's a different benefit it's more like
you have a connection Circle and people
that bounce ideas off of cool but it's
not it's not going to generate business
for you
because you're you're too close even
though your thing is more holistic and
keto might be part of it I'm not part of
it but like the keto woman is not going
to refer business to you probably so the
essential oils person maybe like that's
a probably a closer fit because you
might talk a little bit about essential
oils but it's only like a little piece
of the whole thing because Fitness and
Nutrition is going to be a lot bigger
piece
same thing with anybody who's coming on
and doing a fitness program
would they ever refer clients to you
so again if you just love that person
and you wanna you wanna make you the
relationship is something else it's just
because you love that entrepreneur and
you love hanging out with them cool but
it's not going to lead to business for
you
so that's what in thinking of these
summits
just to tell your story and just to
practice and just getting your message
out there that's a win especially right
now when you're
at the start of sharing all this stuff
so that's great that's amazing
ongoing though you need to start asking
yourself one did I get business from
this event
and two do the do the people here who
are also speaking is there a connection
for me that can help me grow my business
and if too many people are like you and
they won't give you business and you
probably wouldn't pass them on like
you're probably not giving business to
the keto person unless somebody says
Mina like I only want to do keto and I
don't want the holistic thing then you
might say okay well here's go to this
person because I can't help you but
you're probably not referring too many
people to the keto person either where
something like the supplement company or
something like the athletic wear company
or or products around it they're not in
coaching at all
no and you're not in you're not
launching your own line of supplements
yet
yeah
right you're not building your own Nike
you know yet right which is great so
like those are much better ideal
Partnerships for you
because they can refer clients off to
you so that's just how I would evaluate
like this to tell in your store and just
getting it out there in the practice
which is great but then are you getting
business from this and are the people
who are there uh potential referral
partners for you or not you make it
really clear for me because uh I was
thinking about all these things and of
course it's the first time and I don't
know which
direction for now but discussing with
you it's you make it very clear and
digest for me cool I'm glad to help
that's that's uh that's why we do these
things that's why we have Movie Makers
too and listen I think in the beginning
it's good to say yes to things just to
just to experiment and to test and the
try and to see and we actually did I've
been a part of a lot of those different
Summits
um most recently I've said note I think
all of them
um
but we the the one we had we had one we
had a pretty good relationship and we
were actually talking about movement
makers in there and they even actually
helped promote movement makers a lot we
brought in new members through there but
then the follow-up on the accounting and
the it was actually more of a headache
for my team me I don't care I just show
up when I talk and help people but then
Nina my wife who helps like run the
company and then my team
yeah it's like it was too complicated to
work with them it created too much
hassle and too many problems to work
with them so we stopped doing that
relationship
um I love them I mean it was super fun
to do it but I'm not the only one that
matters you know if I'm making a lot
more work for my team then it doesn't
work so those are just some of the
things that you you do and you don't
know until you get into it and you try
so like it's great like you you try a
new food you know you taste it you see
if you like it and if you do you can go
eat some more and if you don't then you
stop so the Summits and that model is a
great thing to test to taste and try and
you're doing it if you're going to keep
like if this is going to be every month
you're going to do it now okay now it
has to it has to start the payoff it's
got to be worth it for you somehow for
your business yes it was
it was exercise to talk without slide
without anything to practice my English
and telling my story it was a good
exercise but uh of course now I have the
vision about how to grow so you make it
really clear for me if I
should continue doing this maybe for
practice okay but not thinking business
100 percent yeah and just see you know
at some point the practice will will
become less and less valuable
yes when we talk about like like today
you did one which is great there's like
learning curve you learned a lot you do
another one and you learn you still
learn but not as much another one you
learn a little bit and then by the time
you're doing your fourth or fifth one it
it might be just you're not getting much
value anymore from the learning so then
is it leading to business growth for you
or not
um one thing I would do is you have a
list of all the speakers right who are
there yeah
this could be a great hack to get more
business is you look at that list
and you see who might be a potential
partner for you
and then you reach out to them and you
say hey I'm Mina
we both spoke at
whatever Summit
uh I you know I was on three hours after
you so we didn't get to connect there
but I I think I'd love to learn more
about your business and have you as a
guest on my podcast
if you think it's a potential referral
partner
the essential oil
or a girl contacted me yes
she sent me a message on messenger
telling me that we can connect after the
summit okay great so so I mean that's
good on her like good job for her to
reach out to you now it's on you is
there anybody else there who might be a
potential partner for you and then you
reach out to them even if you didn't
talk to them at the event
so you look at the list of who the
speakers are going to be whether it's
this event whether it's a future event
whether it's a conference or a trade
show you look at who the list is of the
people and then who might be a potential
partner for you so you say Okay
essential oils yes he don't know you
know Fitness no apparel yes and whoever
else is on the list and then you can
send a message to them to say hey we I
saw you speaking I was a speaker there
too I'd love to have you as a guest on
my show Even if you never met them even
if you never connected at the summit you
have a point of connection which is you
are both speakers at this event
and there might be one other speaker
there besides the essential oils person
who could be a good fit for your show
that then leads to business for you as
well like if there was an apparel
company or another supplement company or
somebody else who was speaking there
you can always reach out even if you
didn't connect at the event
to have them on your show build the
relationship and hopefully get some
referrals a good idea
thank you
and so you can do that for the last one
but then also in the future for any any
ones that are coming up they usually
show their list of of speakers
um so it's an easy way to make a a great
connection as opposed to like just a
cold Instagram where they don't know who
you are yet
yeah uh I I forget but I have I was
reached by an um
a platform asking me to put my podcast
on their platform I did it but I don't
have any idea about uh
the outcome of it and also another app
it was wisdom app I think they asked me
to to make my my YouTube My podcast on
their
platform as well
I didn't do it yet
so here's how that could be helpful for
the most part most platforms you're
probably not going to get a lot of views
or or down or playbacks on any of these
platforms
so you're not doing it because you're
going to get a million people who are
now going to listen to your podcast
because you put it on this network right
but
what you can do is at the beginning when
you're trying to build up your presence
and you're trying to attract people to
come on your show
you can use the fact that you're on
these various platforms as part of the
information about the show
so you can say
uh hey I'm CEO of some supplement
company I love your story I'd love to
have you come on and talk about it on my
new podcast and the podcast gets
distributed
on platform platform platform platform
platform right
and so it makes it look you're using
their name
to make you look bigger than than it is
to get a yes
right so if it's just to try to gain
attention and not it's probably not
worth it because you got to figure out
their platform you got to post there you
got to sign agreement like it's just a
waste of time in terms of just getting
attention for your show
you're for the audience you want to be
on YouTube and then clips for Instagram
Tick Tock that's how you're gonna get
audience but
if somebody went to your YouTube channel
to go there's nothing there yet
so you can say it'll be on YouTube but
it's also we have agreements which you
have to sign an agreement to get it onto
whatever podcast Network right so you
have an agreement with
worth Upworthy and whatever like five
other platforms like it's gonna go to
all these places your show with me so
it's easier to get a yes from them to
want to join that's why I would look at
it is instead of just trying to get uh
attention audience
um at the beginning of my career I did
it for media right so I went after a lot
of media Outlets who went after New York
Times we went after Wall Street Journal
we went after different media Outlets
not because like I got into New York
Times I got in the Wall Street Journal
it did zero for my business
right it's like we got mentioned in New
York Times it's not that like my
business started blowing up and now
everybody cared about me like it did it
did nothing to grow my business apart
from the fact that I can say I've been
in the New York Times
and I've been in the Wall Street Journal
it just adds more credibility
right so being a part of these other
networks you can say I'm part of
Upworthy or whatever and they have a
reach of whatever and I'm part of this
network and they have a read so it just
makes it look bigger than it is uh and
just gives you a little more credibility
coming in compared to if you didn't have
anything else that's how I would
approached those things a new in
broadcasting so I'm learning I'm
learning by the woods
that's great
I think that there are a lot of things
to know to learn from doing
yeah and you're off to a great start and
again for anybody listening watching
like use the podcast for business
development so the guests that you have
coming on are potential referral
partners for you so that they know you
like you trust you they will send
business to you and if you brought on 10
guests and you get one two three people
out of the ten actually send you clients
afterwards because they love you and
what you can provide most people bring
on their competitors or people in their
industry which is a fun conversation
that leads to zero business and so that
little ship is how you can take a brand
new podcast like Mina's creating here
and start actually making some real
money off of it and the focus becomes
selling your thing for 500 to 2500
packages instead of trying to sell her
book or affiliate marketing or these
things that will be will be little
dollars instead of the big dollars
coaching another entrepreneur one-on-one
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there
when you get a group of people together
when you do an event and you've come to
some of my events so you've seen it
right you helped take people to a new
level of confidence and motivation and
that's great but unless you do something
while you're in that state of Commerce
and motivation you go home and you fall
back down where you are